TO AS A SUBCOMMITTEE --
ONE OF WELCOME ISRAEL'S --
TO PRESENT HERE RESOLUTION.
THANK IT WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY JOINT AUTHORED.
OKAY I DIDN'T HAVE HER ON MY
MEMO HERE THAT'S A WELCOME IS
BAKER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
HEARING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS REFERENCED ON PAGE
THREE OF THE ANALYSIS.
WASHINGTON DC HAS EMBARKED ON A
POORLY CRAFTED STRATEGY TO ROLL
BACK THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE TO
CLEAN OUR AIR. FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
NATION COMBATING AUTOMOTIVE
EMISSIONS VIA BIPARTISAN EFFORTS
TO ESTABLISH STANDARDS.
THAT HAVE STE THAT HAVE SERVED
AS A MODEL FOR THE NATION AND
THE WORLD.
THE ILL CONCEIVED PLAN FROM THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY.
AND WILL NOT JUST INCREASE HER
POLICE MISSIONS BUT WILL COST
CONSUMERS MORE.
THE GAS PUMP.
MUST BE STOPPED.
CALIFORNIA'S AUTOMOTIVE
POLLUTION STANDARDS RATHER THAN
BE A BURDEN.
HAVE PUSHED AND ACCELERATED
INNOVATION IN THE AUTOMOTIVE
INDUSTRY.
OUR MODERN CARS PRODUCE FEWER
ADMISSIONS AND HAVE INCREASED
GAS MILEAGE WITHOUT COMPROMISING
PERFORMANCE.
IN FACT MODERN CARS AND TRUCKS
PRODUCE MORE HORSEPOWER.
THAN EVER BEFORE WITH LESS
DISPLACEMENT AND FUEL
CONSUMPTION THEN IT AT ANY OTHER
TIME IN HISTORY.
WITHDRAWING CALIFORNIA'S WAIVER
AND FREEZING THE FUEL ECONOMY IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
STANDARDS.
WILL HAVE A DRASTIC NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AS
WELL.
POTENTIALLY COSTING THE STATE
THIRTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
COSTS.
OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
SUPPORTING AJ OUR FIFTY IS A
VOTE FOR SCIENCE AND CONTINUE
DEVELOPMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES.
ATTACKED OUR AIR WITHOUT
COMPROMISING CONSUMER CHOICE.
WITH ME TO SPEAK ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
IS ONE OF THE JOINT AUTHORS MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
FROM THE CITY OF DUBLIN ERIC AND
HIS BAKER BEFORE YOU GO ON
PROCEED FURTHER ELECTED STEPS
QUORUM.
AND I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MEANT TO CHAIR
REFUGEE HERE ACOSTA HERE ACOSTA
HERE CHAU.
CHOW HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE FLORA.
FLORA HERE IN LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ STONE [inaudible]
STONE HERE.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE QUORUM THANK.
THIS BAKER THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
AFTER A LONG DAY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO THANK --
ART JOINT AUTHORED ASSEMBLY
MEMORY AS A FEW WEEKS AGO WE
BOTH INTRODUCED MEASURES TO
STAND UP FOR CALIFORNIA GETTING
TO KEEP ITS WAVER FROM THE CLEAN
AIR ACT AND CONTINUE --
TO SET STANDARDS THAT THEY FELT
THAT WE BELIEVE ARE CORRECTED
DETERMINE OUR OWN FATE AND OUR
OWN FUTURE WHEN IT COMES TO FUEL
EFFICIENCY AND EMISSION
STANDARDS.
AND I THINK THIS IS AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW INSTEAD OF COMPETING WITH
ONE ANOTHER WE CAN ACTUALLY COME
TOGETHER AND SET.
NOT ONLY GOOD POLICY BUT HAVE A
MUCH STRONGER VOICE BY WORKING
TOGETHER SO I VERY MUCH WANT TO
THANK THE JOINT AUTHOR OF FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AS
SHE HAS OF MANY OTHER ISSUES
RELATED TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
BAD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE A COUPLE
OF KEY POINTS ABOUT THIS WAIVER
AND THIS RESOLUTION.
THE WAIVER WAS FIRST INTRODUCED
IN FIRST REQUESTED.
DECADES AGO BY THEN GOVERNOR
RONALD REAGAN.
JOINT AGENCY.
THEY OF ARMENIA PROTECTION
AGENCY THAT WAS STARTED BY
PRESIDENT NIXON.
AND IT HAS BEEN APPROVED OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TIMES IN FIVE
DECADES.
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
AGAIN AND AGAIN CHOSEN TO SET
ITS OWN FATE AND OWN STANDARDS
THAT LEAD NOT ONLY THE NATION
AND THE WORLD.
SO I UNDERSCORE FOR YOU THE
BIPARTISAN NATURE OF PROTECTING
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
FUEL EFFICIENCY STANDARDS AND
OUR MISSION STANDARDS AND WHY WE
SO VERY MUCH PARTICULARLY AT
THIS TIME NEED TO CONSIDER
CONTINUE THAT EXAMPLE.
SECONDLY AS MIKE ARE GOOD
CALLING GIVES HAS POINTED OUT
THE EFFECTS THAT THE FUEL
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS A
CALIFORNIA SAID HAVE ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT WE MUST CONTINUE TO
DO THEM.
THEY HAVE PROVEN TO HAVE AN
EFFECT NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA
BUT NATIONWIDE AND ACROSS I
THINK THE WORLD.
BUT THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
COMPONENT TO THIS SAID I WANNA
MAKE SURE WE DON'T FORGET AND
THAT IS WHEN WE HAVE PROMOTED
MORE FUEL EFFICIENT VEHICLES AND
OUR STANDARDS WE HAVE ACTUALLY
INCREASED THE AFFORDABILITY.
AND ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION AND
MOBILITY FOR CALIFORNIANS
THERE'S A LOT THAT HAPPENS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT MAKES LIFE LESS
AFFORDABLE. FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE MEASURES
THAT WHEN WE STAND UP FOR FUEL
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS AND THE
WORK THAT CALIFORNIA HAS DONE
THAT ISN'T ALLOWED TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO GET GREATER.
DISTANCES GREATER MOBILITY A
WITH MANY REASONS WHY I HOPE YOU
WILL SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
I'M AND FINALLY I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THATWE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR A NEW WAY.
FOR THIS IS A WAIVER THAT WAS
ALREADY GRANTED WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AS AGAIN A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY WAIVERS HAVE BEEN IN THE
PAST.
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR SPECIAL
TREATMENT --
TO MAKE SURE WE GET A WHOLE
BRAND NEW WAVER WE ALREADY HAVE
ONE WE SECURED IT WE'VE BEEN
PLANNING AND GOING FORWARD WITH
THAT.
ALL WE'RE ASKING IS THAT WE GET
TO CONTINUE UNDER THE FRANKLIN
OF THE PRINCIPLE OF FEDERALISM
THAT STARTED IN OUR OUR
COUNTRY'S CONSTITUTION TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THAT WAIVER.
AND SO --
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK OUR MIKE
VERY GOOD COLLEAGUE THE
ADDITIONAL CO AUTHORS OF THE
LEGISLATION FOR THE BIPARTISAN
VOICE THAT IS SO MUCH STRONGER
FOR THE COLLABORATION FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE FOR THE BIPARTISAN
PRESENTATION --
ON DO WE HAVE A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT YES YOU CAN NOW KEEP A
BRIEF RUPERT PRITCHETT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SONJAY RENT
SHUT WITH TESLA.
DOES NOT SUPPORT AJ ARE FIFTY
AND WE THANK THE AUTHORS FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP.
TESLA'S MISSION IS TO ACCELERATE
THE WORLD'S TRANSITION TO
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY.
WE ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST
MANUFACTURING EMPLOYERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
AND WHERE THE ONLY AUTOMAKER
BUILDING PASSENGER VEHICLES AT
SCALE IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL TESLA BIGGLES ARE ZERO
MISSION AND BUILT IN CALIFORNIA
AT OUR FACTORY IN FREMONT.
THIS IS NOT A COINCIDENCE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE NATION'S
STRONGEST POLICIES TO REDUCE
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS.
THANKS TO YOUR SUPPORT.
AND MORE CLEAN CARS ON THE ROAD
THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
IT'S CRITICAL THE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY.
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS OF HARMFUL
AIR POLLUTANTS THAT HARM THE
HEALTH OF OUR CITIZENS.
AND SET OUR OWN CLEAN CAR RULES
IN ORDER TO DO SO.
TESLA'S ALIGNED WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN DEFENDING
AGAINST ATTACKS BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ON FEDERAL CLEAN
CAR RULES.
SHORTLY AFTER ATTORNEY GENERAL
BUT SARAH FILED SUIT.
AGAINST USEPA IN MID APRIL FOR
ITS DECISION TO WITHDRAW THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S SO CALLED
MID TERM EVALUATION.
TESLA JOINED THE NATIONAL
COALITION FOR ADVANCED
TRANSPORTATION AND CHALLENGING
THAT DECISION.
TESLA IS PROUD TO PARTNER WITH
THE STATE. TO ACHIEVE OUR SHARED
CLEAN AIR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
AND CLIMATE GOALS AND WE'RE
WORKING HARD TO HELP ME.
AND EXCEED THE NEW GOAL OF FIVE
MILLION ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON
CALIFORNIA ROADS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY WE APPEAR TO BE
THE ONLY AUTOMAKER SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION.
JUST LIKEWE MAY BE THE ONLY
AUTOMAKER STANDING WITH THE
STATE AND COURT THE CHALLENGE
THE ROLLBACK FEDERAL CLEAN CAR
RULES.
IT'S ALL THE MORE REASON THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR TO PASS THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE LIKE TO COMMENT ON
THIS PLEASE COMPORT.
GOOD EVENING ELEANOR TEAS ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND AND SUPPORT THINK YOU.
GOOD EVENING TO GET A CARD WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE KEEP FOR HE'S AND SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS AND NEXT
GEN.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD SEEING NONE --
ANY -- THE
FINAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE BY MS EGGMAN
SECOND BY MISTER CHOW LIKE
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY S. FREE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU --
CHARGE RECOMMENDATION IS THAT
AYE MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL.
EDU ARE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAYOS THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
AS AMENDED.
MEMBERS ROUTE SUCI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
LIMON.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S [inaudible]
MELENDEZ NO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I IT'S ONE SIX ONE THE THE
RESOLUTION IS OUT.
THANK YOU SOLUTIONS [inaudible]
WE ARE WAITING FOR MISTER BLOOM
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
NO.
SHE CAN ADD ON ALRIGHT WE ARE
WAITING FOR MISTER BLOOM
--
BELIEVE SO
.
I ENERGY OTHER AREAS ARE RIGHT.
WELCOME MR BLOOM.
MY FATHER PASSED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
WELCOME MISTER MILLER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THAT SEPTEMBER THE STATE WILL
HOLD MCGUIRE GLOBAL CLIMATE
ACTION SUMMIT.
AS YOU ALL KNOW.
WHERE GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS
LEADERS FROM AROUND THE WORLD?
WE'LL BE ASKED TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
PAST COMMITMENTS.
AND I'M OUT OF BREATH CATCH A
PRACTICAL.
IT'S THOSE DAMN STAIRS.
OUR THIS AJ R. EMPHASIZES THE
NEED.
FOR AND BURKE ZWEITEN PLAN THE
BASEBALL GAME.
WE THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SKINNER.
COULD HAVE HIT --
BUT AND THIS BILL IS GOING TO
EMPHASIZE SAID THE NEED.
FOR ENVIRONMENTALLY JUST
PROGRAMS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE A RIGHT THAT YOU HAVE
A WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THE
RESOLUTION.
BOB GOOD EVENING CHAIRING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BY THEN SHOT
OFF ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE COMPLIANCE
WHEREIN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR.
FORTY SEVEN WHICH AFFIRMS
COMPANIES LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS THE
PERVASIVE CHALLENGES OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CHANGING OCEAN
CONDITIONS [inaudible]
ARE.
AS THE MEMBER EXPLAINED
CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO HOSTING
THE GLOBAL CLIMATE ACTION SUMMIT
--
TIMBRE GOV WE'RE GOVERNMENTS IT
AND BUSINESSES WILL BE COMING
TOGETHER TO MAKE A BOMB AND
RECOMMIT.
ATTITUDE.
TO MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION OF
BEARS CLIMATE CHANGE RULES OZ
WAS LUCIAN WOULD URGE FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
TAKE SPECIFIC ACTION TO PRESERVE
THE STATE'S OCEAN COASTAL
RESOURCES AS WELL AS PROTECT
THIS ADVANCE AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ATTACKED BY THESE
CHALLENGES.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AJ OR FORTY
SEVEN RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU RIGHT
NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF FURTHER
THEM THEM BEHALF OF US WHO LIVE
IN OUR DOORS.
THE CALIFORNIA THEY PLANT
SOCIETY AND OUT ON CALIFORNIA
HALL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS
NUCLEAR CREDIT WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINK THANK YOU.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME.
FOR SAYING DOT QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MOTIONS BEEN MADE
AND SECONDED TO MISTER BLOOM
WHICH ARE CLOSE.
THANK YOU THAT'S IT THAT'S PURE
AYE VOTE --
CHURCH RECOMMENDATIONS AND AYE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ITEM ONE HR FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM THE MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MARTUCCI AYE MURATSUCHI
AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FLORA
AYE FLORA AYE ON THE MOON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA NO STONE BY
STONE AYE [inaudible] SEVEN ONE
SEVEN ONE THE RESOLUTION IS OUT
[inaudible]
DIDN'T DISAPPOINT.
ALRIGHT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED